nell episodio precedente oddio che cazzo
è una bambola quella
cazzo non è una bambola ho trovato un
posto segreto a trovare nella porta
principale oddio a dei sotterranei in
teoria dovrebbero essere qui sotto per
tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video io sono fuori j
oggi siamo qui sul secondo episodio di
mez vader prima d'iniziare ragazzi
volevo ringraziarvi di cuore perché mi
avete chiesto di continuare questa
splendida serie perché sono veramente
contento che lo abbiate apprezzato a
molti diciamo si fermano giudicare dice
una grafica dei videogame invece voi
siete andati oltre questo mi avete
diciamo chiesto di continuarlo perché
avete capito che la storia veramente
fantastica
io stesso reputo questo un grandissimo
titolo sono non l'avrei mai iniziato e
quindi sono veramente contento che sia
piaciuto anche a voi quindi da adesso in
avanti cercherò di narrare come si deve
cercherò di far la voce di personaggi si
ci proverò a ridurlo anche i tagli se
riesco quindi direi di iniziare va beh
scusate la premessa come al solito
andiamo su continua allora eravamo
rimasti nella perfetto
eravamo rimasti in questo stronzo
fantastica piena di sangue c'è scritto
amerai che anche detto che cosa c'è
scritto ma non mi ricordo più
eravamo rimasti che dovevamo andare nel
sotterraneo salvare il nostro padre
perché si era sentito un urlo eh va beh
non siamo ancora arrivati va bene direi
di andare di sotto
non mi ricordo a ecco perfetto c'era
tutto sto casino di mostri messi insieme
buongiorno mi fate passare ai kings
kruder ho capito ci avrei scommesso
neanche amici stufare a bomba lì in
mezzo comunque va beh direi di tornare
indietro
vabbè andiamo dove cazzo dovrei andare a
sto punto seri non ci posso andare
allora ecco mi avete anche detto sì
perché ha tra l'altro cambiato la
posizione nella webcam perché a sinistra
copriva il menu mi avete detto che il
coltello serve ad aprire una scatola di
sopra vi ringrazio veramente era nel
bagno comunque va beh vi ringrazio per
avermelo detto non mi ha stuprato che è
perfetto miri vi ringrazio per avermelo
detto perché non ci sarei mai arrivato
la scatola dovrebbe essere questa se non
sbaglio
vediamo
chissà che minchia c'è lì dentro cosa un
pacco regalo è un accendino vuoto ok un
accendino voto che cazzo me ne faccio
niente è che cazzo me ne faccio lì nasce
il vino vuoto
e vabbè amica c'e l'olio per l'accendino
allora si riempie volo perfetto ci siamo
forse ci siamo
aspettate un attimo che cazzo sta
riempiendo una caraffa anno perfetto
godel l'ater prefetto ci siamo con
l'accendino e che cosa mica me ne faccio
e l'accendino fatemi capire allora
fatemi pensare che cazzo mi servono
accendino
dov'è che non sono andato che mi serviva
un accendino non lo so forse li cazzo
dimenticato c'erano sti cosi va beh non
mi ricordo precisamente dove dovevo
andare forse dovrà accendere i fornelli
no veramente qui ce l'ho già stato
allora ragazzi sta confondendo il sotto
non ci possono dare precedenza non è che
mi fa proprio dal fuoco prova a dargli
fuoco no niente non fa quando fa corano
anche fuoco pini non serve a un cazzo ad
andare di somma se punterà ad ora siamo
qui c'è
besta stanza non penso che non serva che
c'è sempre sta portando no capito come
si apre tanto è tutto chiuso
mi servono delle armi vita anche detto
che c'era una specie di mi avete detto
che se non scappare a perfetto forse
questo no non è questo cazzate c'è uno
scaffale particolare laddove dovrebbe
scendere qualcosa mi pare avete detto mi
ricordo cosa forse questo ricordo che di
questo libro c'è una ragazza che ha un
misterioso potere al misterioso potere
di controllare fuoco andato in un
viaggio ha viaggiato per trovare la
famiglia da quel dalla quale è stata
separata dicendo brucerò qualsiasi cosa
dal mio passaggio e ha fatto esattamente
quello che ha detto ma io credo nella
fine il suo potere è andato fuori
controllo e ha distrutto il mondo che
bel racconto verrà conto per bambini
così lei non ha mai conosciuto la sua
famiglia fino alla fine
ed è rimasta per sempre sola non povera
ragazza sola bello fantastico sono
veramente mi chiami mi hai migliorato
l'umore cazzo
io se io perdessi papa sarei solo
anch'io si e non voglio esserlo va bene
andiamo a salvare papa ma se leggi
vivrei non facciamo un cazzo hai have to
syd possono fare mio padre alla veloce
bene se smetti di leggere brava hai
capito
salviamo innanzitutto allora perfetto ci
siano
devo capire che cazzo fare allora gli
scaffali non servono a niente mi mentite
devo andare che questa è chiusa cosa che
cazzo adesso si è svegliata già adesso
mi me ne se ne esce dicendo che poi
bruciare quei cosi se usano cazzo fa
qualcosa cioè un'ora che giro con un
[ __ ] ma se ci sono passato di qui
che prima c'è chi cazzo ok bene
brucia fantastiche terre set mi fa male
aiutatemi non vi aiuta un cazzo andiamo
avanti
hai già fatto un casino hai fatto a me
non importa se ce l'abbiamo fatta
no perché sul contratto in via fatemi
salvare primo ok allora ragazzi
probabilmente dovevo leggere quella roba
nelle librerie quella storia della
ragazza di fuoco o di prima che che mi
avrebbe fatto capire che dovevo bruciare
quei cosi c'è un casino vabbè ci siano
vai possiamo passare grande ci ho messo
un secolo stiamo siamo arrivati i
ragazzoni sotterranei allora l'acqua
dovrebbe esserci mio padre perfetto vai
ci dovrebbe essere ok
salviamo vai questa è la porta permesso
che cazzo maria c'è ancora vivo a questa
sì sei bendata si 6 bendata si però sono
stato bene ok ha già mi son dimenticato
che devo fare le voci l'agri non mi fate
farsa corda beh ci prova dai
va beh lei la facciona dimenticami
scappa in qualsiasi posto che sia sicuro
e per il troppo pericoloso qui dove a
lasciarti tornare in un'altra stanza a
devo salvare il dottore
ok mica questa non era una voce poco da
donna non puoi andarci con quelle band
ma maria cos'è successo papa il dottore
è fuggito con sua moglie sua moglie lei
insomma ogni mia mamma
ma che stai dicendo maria maria la madre
dovrebbe essere morta in teoria però
vabbè
mi sembrava che fosse passato ok c'è di
nuovo il professor layton
ad ogni modo sembra che tuo padre se ne
sia andato in profondità in un labirinto
sotterraneo rider passata di qui che
cosa sta succedendo in questo modo stai
soltanto confermando i sospetti non
credi dove cazzo vai
oddio a risolvere enigmi perfetto quello
strano ragazzo perfetto ci siamo alla
ragazza maria e mezza morta va bene ora
guardate bene il suo sacchetto ve lo
ricordate
c'è c'è sacchetto paranormal pattumiera
è lui
paranormal pattumiera vabbè andiamo
avanti devo a perseguiamo professor
layton ok c'è papà cazzo cosa ci fa
linea pro
a sti cazzi del balcone 2 vabbè ma
sicuro
aspetta che cazzo si è portata via papa
non ci posso credere è veramente la
mamma credo di sì non hai notato
qualcosa ma che cazzo
non è con che spunta ovunque la tragedia
che ha portato qui
la maledizione di toama secret raga io
credo che la mamma sia qui perché il
padre effettivamente l'ha uccisa
tan tan tan 0 va bene continuiamo a noi
non sapremo mai chi che mandiamo avanti
la maledizione che ha portato alla morte
di tuo padre
quindi quella donna produssero sì quindi
ha realizzato quella e tua madre
si sia aperto la porta tso non vorrei
proprio andare lì dentro ma vabbè
andiamoci stanza dei cadaveri atmosfera
cazzo cazzo
c'è una testa perché ok guerra e sbarre
dov'è il mio corpo benissimo ok se mi fa
schifo anche a me a sentire una testa
che parla così va bene
paranormal pattumiera ovunque direi di
andare dove cazzo se dove cazzo sarei
portato a mio padre che è in avanti
ragazzacce della dinamite
oh mio dio devo trovare un punto di
salvataggio perché se no non vado tanto
avanti è perfetto buio non vedo un cazzo
saliamo le scale e spero di trovare un
corpo per non puoi perché se no non
posso salvare la partita
ok a porta a porta sbloccata perché
ok siamo tornati su perfetto allora il
corvo ce l'abbiamo
adesso che siamo tornati su possiamo
muoverci più velocemente perfetto
direi di andare avanti allora sì eravamo
rimasti che devo trovare praticamente
mia madre che ha rapito mio padre
raga la trama si infittisce
chi cazzo era quello avete visto anche
voi c'era qualcuno qui non me lo sono
immaginato
credo veramente c'era qualcuno qui non
me lo sono immaginato chi è che se
qualcuno mi spia li tira un cazzotto un
altro corpo perfetto
devo trovare non vede un cazzo non si
può usare tipo l'accendino per fare più
luce no non posso farlo pero no va bene
anche perché non so proprio l'accendino
ma non importa allora c'è un'altra scala
qui che credo sia l'unica hai preso
scala a ok possiamo andare nella tic ora
che abbiamo preso il prezzo della scala
quindi direi ritornare indietro allora
andiamo avanti dobbiamo tornare nell
attico questo punto dove c'era la scala
incompleta diciamo all'arci siamo non so
sinceramente che cosa ci può essere
nell'attico però va bene metti la scala
mettila ad emetterla io forse vai
ci siamo grandissimo fantasy cosa ci
siamo vai così c'è una gemma l'ho visto
anche prima alla rai peso gemma perfetto
devo buttare l'amica risotto sta cosa ok
si è spaccata
ovviamente c'è qualcosa di qui speriamo
che sia non lo so perché non ne dai che
cazzo mi possa servire per andare avanti
una chiave
questa è una una motosega che cazzo mi
ci faccio una motosega
oh mio dio no veramente la motosega era
l'ultima cosa che mi aspettavo di usare
premi il tasto speciale per equipaggio
la motosega professore normalmente
equipaggiata nel sotterraneo quando
equipaggiata premi il tasto conferma per
far si che hai a faccia notare la
motosega faccia notare la motosega va
beh certi oggetti come barili cos'è
volte possono essere distrutte grazie a
questo non può essere utilizzata per
attaccare i nemici 7 come no kat una
motosega
vabbè ma attenzione che non puoi aprire
me nuovo a dare oggetti finché la
motosega fuori va bene che non sta come
che nostalgia e cazzo vuol dire che
nostalgia perché giocare con la motosega
la piccola che già sei piccola va beh
ricordo mia prendere che giocava con
festa come giocava con questa ma come ma
che ti faceva giocare con la moto set va
beh non voglio fare domande ma no ma
cosa ma come fai a giocare con la foto
sega ma perché è una bambina deve
giocare con le motoseghe
vabbè perché sei dirottando perché se
giocando con la motosega scusami eh
scusami un cazzo va beh questo non è un
giocattolo ma va
e veramente pericoloso è capito mai
giocare con la motosega ancora scusa
papa sono sicuri sono contento che non
si sia fatta male pensavo potesse essere
ovunque al di fuori la tua portata
e invece no dove chi allora l'hai
trovata aia scusami sposami book
ok mi fa tenerezza morire sì anche lui
piange va bene
ok abbiamo capito che lei giocava con le
motoseghe da lollipop chainsaw vabbè
lasciamo stare allora con shift la tirò
fuori con z la uso per spaccata perfetto
che figo posso devo dire la roba se vai
cos'è demoliamo tutto vai madonna mia
santissima ai cos'è demoliamo qualsiasi
cosa è il problema è che non so che
cazzo mi può servire tranne che va beh
abbiamo una motosega questo è un passo
avanti che prima non ho sfondato va beh
noi proviamo che cazzo è successo perché
inciampato a che cosa è successo ho
sentito qualcosa farmi la gamba cosa che
cazzata afferrato la zio che è quella di
the grudge la loro striscia non star di
ok vai vai
[Musica]
beh allora c'è cazzola non posso fare
remix che cazzo è successo qualcuno mi
aveva afferrato per la gamba non so chi
o mio dio è stato traumatico attenzione
che io c'è una motosega
c'è una motosega non ha paura di usarla
ma non posso dire alla fuori perché non
posso dare la moto è a posto sanno
soltanto nei sotterranei ok a pini non
serve un cazzo venire qui perché ho
fatto il nostro passaggio
posso usarla soltanto nei sotterranei
allora che cazzo ci son venuto a fare
qua fatemi capire
vabbè andiamo avanti vediamo se riesco a
tirarla fuori secco ok
devo però che cazzo ci devo fare
iniziati errani questa roba non c'è
nulla da buttar giù assi qua ci sono
altri marini vai a circa una porta cazzo
l'avevo vista ok ragazzi sia ma possiamo
andare avanti e fatemi salvare perfetto
si sta infittendo veramente la trama è
fantastica e non vedo l'ora di scoprire
di più cos'è cos'è sta roba terra cos'è
è semplicemente un solco si fantastica
oh mio dio e lui non ci credo è il
maestro muten ma anche incazzo cipale un
vecchio uomo sta borbottando con se
stesso ma non lo so che cosa cazzo sta
borbottando è drogato ma una gemma ho
trovato una gemma benissimo ci sono le
gemme che non ho ancora capito che cazzo
mi servono ma
raccogliendo tutte beh ci siamo che
cazzo di posto è questo mi ricorda
penombra bene andiamo avanti
direi di ok ragazzi
salve chi cazzo sei hai chiusa
dall'interno per apri apri apri a piedi
non ama o dio perché non ci ha gli occhi
non posso vedere non posso vedere niente
oh cazzo quell'uomo mi ha portato via
gli occhi ma che schifo ma cazzo ma vera
gara io direi di chiudere qui l'episodio
anche perché sta diventando macabro mi
avete detto tutti anche che tra un po
inizierà a fare veramente paura
quindi direi che siamo arrivati al punto
limite raga e non oso pensare che cosa
succederà nelle prossime puntate
io per questo episodio la chiudo qui se
mi è piaciuto video come al solito
lasciato un commento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e come ogni video
trovate nella descrizione se non siete
ancora iscritti scrive che vende ci
vediamo in un prossimo video mela
ragazzi